justice true justice will not come
until we finally banish the ancient
poison of racism
from the american soul the senate will
continue to work that work
as we strive to ensure that george
floyd's tragic death will not be in vain
we will not rest until the senate passes
strong legislation
to end the systemic bias in law
enforcement
now on a related subject part of that
effort
though modest is installing committed
experienced compassionate civil rights
leaders
in positions of power in the justice
department
our nation's top law enforcement agency
it just so happens that today the senate
will vote on the confirmation of miss
venita gupta to be the next associate
attorney general not only is ms gupta
the first woman of color to ever be
nominated
to the position she is the first civil
rights attorney
ever to be nominated to the position the
third
ranking official in the justice
department
that's shocking really we never have had
a former civil rights attorney
serving in such a prominent searching in
such a position of prominence at the
justice department
in that sense alone mrs gupta
would bring a long overdue perspective
to our federal
law enforcement agency and just to give
you a sense of ms gupta's commitment to
civil rights and racial equity
in her very first case after law school
she won the release of several
african-americans who had been wrongly
convicted
by all white juries in texas her clients
later won a full pardon from texas
governor rick perry
at a time when our country needs to make
strides against racial injustice how can
we not install one of the nation's top
civil rights lawyers
at the department of justice how can our
colleagues
not rise to the occasion or colleagues
on the other side of the aisle and vote
for her
i'm so so troubled by the fact that they
are virtually unanimously against
such a fine person who is needed so much
at this time yep
but unfortunately ms gupta might be the
first nominee this cong
in this congress where the vote falls
entirely down on party lines
i hope it doesn't come to that the
effort to elevate highly qualified civil
rights attorneys like miss gupta should
be bipartisan
i urge my colleagues all of them and
particularly my friends on the other
side of the aisle
to vote in favor of miss gupta's
nomination
today competitiveness on a different
matter here
for nearly a century america's national
security
and economic security has been grounded
in our scientific and technological
superiority
often supported by smart investments by
the federal government
but in recent years countries like china
have closed the gap with the united
states
if we fail to respond they will overtake
us with drastic consequences for our
workers businesses
and allies and partners around the world
it's long past time for the united
states to make the next wave of
investments to fix
dangerous weak spots in our economy and
preserve our place
as the world leader in science and
technology which then leads to millions
of good-paying jobs here in this country
so today i'm proud to join with my
friend the republican senator from
indiana senator young
and several of my colleagues from both
sides to reintroduce the endless
frontier act
it's a big bold bipartisan initiative to
propel american science and technology
into the 21st century
let me stress that that last point
this bill is bipartisan as senator young
and i have worked on the bill over the
past several months
several senators from both sides have
been added as original co-sponsors six
democrats and six republicans
that's because there's a bipartisan
consensus that the united states must
invest
in the technologies of the future to out
compete china
whichever nation develops new
technologies first
be they democratic or authoritarian will
set
the terms for their use the stakes for
personal privacy and personal liberties
as well as for national security
economic security and minority rights
around the globe
are simply enormous so at the center of
this legislation is a hundred billion
dollar investment in research
commercialization and workforce training
in the kinds of technology that will
play an outsized role in the future
semiconductors artificial intelligence
quantum computing
5g to name a few
another 10 billion would foster the
development of technological hubs around
the country
we want to see silicon valleys across
the country
from my home state new york in upstate
to communities in the south to the
midwest to other places that
rarely get the attention they merit
despite the potential of their
workforces their institutions and their
links to the global economy
technological growth in jobs should not
be limited to a few centers in america
and this bill attempts to spread it to
other communities as well
it will also strengthen the critical
supply chains in the u.s
with global allies and partners the
endless frontiers act is exactly what we
need to invigorate reinvigorate american
science and technology
to promote our national security and
create
jobs of the future i have committed to
put a bipartisan
related bill on the floor of the senate
the endless uh comp i have i have
committed to put a bipartisan
competitive related bill on the floor of
the senate
the endless frontier act will be a
central part of that legislation
we will also push for emergency spending
to implement
the bipartisan semiconductor
manufacturing provisions
in last year's defense bill and another
potential component
led by senators menendez and risch is
being marked up in the senate foreign
relations committee this week
this is exactly what our republican
colleagues have asked for when it comes
to regular order
we are marking up bipartisan bills in
committee and considering bipartisan
amendments here on the floor
we're just seeing this that process play
out on the anti-asian hate crimes bill
this week
and next week we're going to follow it
up with a water infrastructure bill that
is also thoroughly bipartisan
our efforts to cement another century
of american economic leadership should
be no different
thoroughly bipartisan i yield the floor
and note the absence of a crime critical
this baldwin
i swear
is
more and more